monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
pris il y a environ 15 jours en conseil
des ministres une ordonnance sur la
prise en charge des conséquences des
désordres causés par le phénomène
naturel de mouvement de terrain
différentiel comme le texte l'a rappelé
plus de la moitié des maisons
individuelles en France sont construites
sur des sols argileux susceptibles de
présenter un risque moyen ou fort de
dégâts provoqué par un phénomène naturel
de succession d'épisodes de sécheresse
et de réhumidification des sols de plus
sous l'effet du réchauffement climatique
nous savons que la planète connaîtra
davantage d'épisodes de chaleur extrême
avec des épisodes de sécheresse plus
sévères et récurrents comme la
soulignait notamment la fédération
professionnelle France assureur qui
chiffre les sinistres à 43 milliards
d'euros entre 2020 et 2050 3 fois plus
que les 13,8 milliards indemnisés sur la
période de 1989 à 2019 pourtant si le
phénomène de retrait gonflement des sols
argileux est étudiés et documentés en
France depuis plusieurs années il y a
encore une méconnaissance des sinistrés
et des acteurs locaux sur l'impact de la
sécheresse et de ce phénomène sur le
bâti et les dispositions descriptif pour
s'en prémunir les sinistrés se sentent
ainsi souvent démunies face au coup des
travaux et à l'impact psychologique que
peut induire la dégradation de leurs
habitations face à ce constat ne
serait-il pas plus judicieux monsieur le
ministre ne trouvait des solutions
durables afin de prévenir au mieux ce
phénomène il y a aujourd'hui une
obligation d'étude des sols mais qu'en
est-il de l'obligation de construction
pour mettre à l'abri les fructures
propriétaires que prévoit le
gouvernement à ce sujet ma deuxième
question concerne les victimes au-delà
de la compensation financière que
prévoit le gouvernement pour les
accompagner dans la transformation de
leur maison afin que celle-ci s'adapte
au mieux à ses mouvements de sol dû à la
sécheresse je vous remercie